as the war in ukraine enters its fourth
month president vladimir zelinsky is
dispelling hopes of negotiations with
russia any time soon in his latest video
address zielinski called russia's
aggression an evil that can only be
contained on the battlefield
ukraine says russia is stepping up its
attacks in the eastern donbass region
with ukrainian troops doing everything
possible to hold their ground
authorities said russia's advantage in
arms and equipment was making the
situation very difficult but in his
nightly address on monday zielinski
remained defiant
russia is very nervous about our
activity
there has been more shelling of
and odessa
they have been more brutal assaults in
the donbas
this is an evil that can only be
defeated on the battlefield
we're defending
this whole region is the most difficult
these are the hardest fights
and let's bring in nick connolly from a
key for now uh nick evil can only be
defeated on the battlefield those are
some fighting words from a president
who's by his own admission uh is having
a trouble getting the arms he needs to
fight the war
that's definitely the case but i think
that was a signal here from kiev also to
the west and particularly to western
european countries that ukraine is
basically not going to be willing to
talk to russia until those russian
troops are forced back to where they
were on february 24th at the beginning
of this war there had been significant
fears here in kiev that there would be
an attempt by maybe france germany italy
when we had that visit of the leaders
three leaders to kiev last week to try
and force ukraine to some kind of
compromises to basically end this war in
a hurry to end this uh spike in energy
prices and basically get back to
business as normal with russia at the
cost of ukraine and its territorial
integrity and i think ukraine feels
vindicated and relieved that that didn't
happen that they were able to make their
case and with support from the u.s and
the uk prevent a kind of diplomatic
initiative from western european
countries into forcing ukraine basically
to
play to russia's terms
but it is definitely a very difficult
situation for ukraine right now they are
able to hold up the front lines and
russia is making gains but very modest
gains but that
disproportion in terms of the resources
russia has some say ten to one in terms
of artillery that is definitely
something that is costing ukrainian
lives
and nick you were mentioning the eu and
of course there was the troika of
european union leaders who promised to
support canada's sea status for the for
ukraine to the european union there's a
decision coming up thursday friday
how would membership when it comes
change the
change the country and what is the
candidacy mean to zielinski and
ukrainians
obviously membership is something that a
vast majority of ukrainian citizens
want all the sociology uh shows that
massive majority for that here it would
basically end decades-long speculation
about where ukraine is going for the
most of its independence ukraine has
basically been a buffer zone between
russia and uh western europe and the eu
and basically has been spent spending
its time rather than kind of developing
its economy uh stuck with these kind of
geopolitical questions so that would put
those to bed once and for all and
obviously you'll be a huge economic
boost and open the door to huge
investment in this country that has
historically underperformed and you know
still has some of the lowest average
incomes in europe and even just being a
candidate would already put ukraine on a
road map forced reforms that would bring
in investments way before eventual
membership we've seen that in poland in
the baltic states in uh neighboring
romania so even before ukraine becomes a
member that would have an impact that
would be felt by ordinary ukrainians
pretty soon
okay nick connolly reporting for us from
kiev thanks for that
since the beginning of the war
volunteers across ukraine have been
doing their part for the war effort some
are turning to recycling to help save
soldiers lives
to find out more about how it's done
dw's rebecca ritters traveled to
southern ukraine to the region around
mika live
this old junkyard is a junkyard no more
when war broke out volunteers took over
the space and turned it into a military
workshop
diemer is a sound engineer and voice
over artist
now he makes flak jackets
bulletproof vests were requested so we
decided to try and make some a small
number thirty pieces we wanted to raise
forty seven thousand herifa for that
but people felt so connected that we
raised 150 000 in the first three to
four days so we made three times as many
so far they've sent more than seven
hundred of the vests to the front lines
places like hardkiv chernahev and
mikolaiv there's recycling involved and
the work looks artisanal but the product
is military-grade
this metal is certified eight
millimeters thick
this rubber from a conveyor belt is
glued on top of it it acts as an
anti-fragmentation layer this rubber
traps all splinters from the bullet
the metal and rubber are bound together
in strong tape and we make holy cross
here
it's a joke that's a joke but i hope it
works
fireproof material usually used to make
sofas forms the outer shell of the vests
just pop the plates inside these
purpose-built pockets and hey presto
well the vest feels pretty good once you
get it on it's quite comfortable
and much lighter than you might expect
much lighter than some of the press
vests i've even had to wear in the field
but the real test of course is going to
be whether or not
it can stop a bullet
the plates deflect shots from an ak-47
standard equipment for the russian army
outside he shows us old tractor wheels
that will go into some of the vests
soldiers arrive to pick up some for the
comrades
they learn what kind of bullets their
new body armor can stop
a quick trip into the shop to take what
they need then they're off to the front
lines with gear to save lives made in
ukraine
russia is tightening its grip on the
occupied regions of ukraine a sign that
it has no intention of relinquishing
control of these areas
the russian defense ministry says it has
repaired nearly 1200 kilometers of
damaged railway in the country's
southeast the tracks link russia with
the occupied areas in the donbass gerson
and crimea it will allow moscow to send
in more troops and weapons
the kremlin also announced that water is
again flowing through the north korean
rather crimean canal the canal once
provided most of the peninsula's fresh
water following russia's annexation of
crimea in 2014 ukraine built a dam in
the town of kalanchak cutting off this
vital supply
russia is also attempting to russify the
population in occupied ukraine to
solidify its rule there it has been
handing out russian passports and
introduced the ruble as the official
currency it's also changed the telephone
country code and is broadcasting russian
television
and i'm joined now by war expert and
former british army officer mike martin
for more on this mike it appears that
russia is seeking to annex the occupied
territories completely what are the
chances of success
good morning
um i i think that their chances of
success are going to be um
bedeviled by the same problem that the
russians have had throughout the war and
that's not having enough troops for what
they seek to do
um if we look around the country at the
moment there are three areas where there
are fighting in the north around kharkiv
in the east in donbass that we hear so
much about and in the south in kharsan
that you were just speaking about in
order to make progress in the east the
russians had to take out troops from the
north and the south and so they simply
just don't have enough troops to do what
they want to do
and there's considerable resistance as
well from the population in some places
behind the front lines how much of that
is going to is a challenge or will be a
challenge for russia
exactly i think it's already a challenge
as well as not being able to hold uh or
make progress on different the different
front lines that they hold uh in the
south around her son
we've seen quite significant partisan
activity
for example a couple of days ago there
was a bomb attack against a
the head of the prison service in hassan
originally a ukrainian collaborator who
switched sides to the russians so he was
attacked and blown up and we're starting
to see
attacks on arms dumps behind russian
lines
they simply just don't have enough
troops to cope with a restive ukrainian
population that doesn't want them there
and if we can just turn to the to the
donbass region for a second ukrainian
military officials admit themselves this
will be a decisive week why is that
well i i would slightly caveat that the
ukrainians have been saying that each
week is decisive in the donbass
and they're doing i think what we'd all
do they're using the battle as a way to
make sure that the west continues with
its arms deliveries
having said that
the pocket of ukrainian forces in the
city of sura donetsk which is what we've
heard so much about in the last couple
of weeks is now reduced down to one
small area so it is likely that the
ukrainians are going to have to either
surrender that pocket or pull out it's
very similar actually to the situation
in mariupol about a month ago but once
they do that
they still hold mr chance which is the
next door uh city which is just across a
river and it's on top of a hill so it's
much more militarily uh defendable
a final question if i may about that
great intangible morale who's winning
the moral war
oh
ukraine without a doubt uh and since the
beginning of the war that's been the
case
that is largely down to one
big factor which is the ukrainians are
fighting for the defense of their
homeland whereas the russians have a
conscript army in some cases they're
press ganging civilians into that army
and the differences in morale are are
completely uh very high for the
ukrainians are very low for the russians
i think you had a piece there that was
an excellent example of that civilians
who were running a factory that made
something else suddenly switched to
making body armor and the ukrainian
troops were coming and getting that body
armor having a coffee and then going
back to the front line these are the
actions of a country and of a military
that have high morale
okay military expert mike martin
thanks so much
thank you
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians fled
to germany after russia's invasion in
february now even with desperate
fighting continuing in their countries
east some ukrainians are deciding to
return home dw news found out why
these buses are taking ukrainian
refugees back home
as the russian aggression shifted to the
east of ukraine more and more people are
daring to go back to safer areas
svetlana haldetsuka and daughters vlada
and zhenya are waiting for a bus to give
i miss home i miss our house i want to
go back
[Music]
we miss friends miss the family people
we haven't seen for over three months
now
and it's hard to be on the road like
that all the time
with some of them it's not even possible
to connect online so i just want to see
them
but their mother svetlana is worrying
about the trip
vlada wants to go home i can't send her
to kiev and stay here myself from a
rational point of view it's definitely
safer here because he cannot know how
will russia act
[Music]
over 800 000 ukrainian refugees have
arrived in germany since russia's attack
in february
but the new arrivals have been
decreasing for weeks
now more people are leaving the eu back
to ukraine than entering from there
my husband is a soldier he's in a
hospital now
and he doesn't have anyone besides us
does that do him
i miss my home my car my garden and i
miss ukraine
i want to see my relatives and ukraine
too but i'll come back because i come
from my goliath and it's close to where
the battle is happening so now i'm just
going there for a short time
some experts now expect circular
migration of the refugees the drivers
bring people in both directions
we drive every day from ukraine and to
ukraine our company sends six to seven
buses and all of them are full with 60
people inside
finally spitlana and vlada's bus arrives
the older daughter zhenya bids them
firewell she will stay in berlin for a
few more weeks and join them in july
provided that is that the war doesn't
make this family and others run from
ukraine again